In this presentation I will solve a set of questions about the tendency
With little review, the tendency is a method
To measure the slope of the line
And the definition - I hope we get
Good knowledge of him in this offer - and his definition
Is the change in y التغير the change in x
Perhaps this is not clear to you now, but whenever
We analyzed more and more issues, I think it would be a good thing
So it is clear to us
Let's solve the first line
Line a
Let's find his inclination
We have two points here that we can use
As reference points
If first, let me look at
These coordinates are points
We have this point
What are its coordinates?
The x coordinate is 3
The y coordinate is 6
At the bottom here, this point is an x-coordinate
-1 and its coefficients are -6
There are a number of ways we can think about it
The first is, we can look at its integrity using the formula
We can say the change in y - the inclination is the change in y /
Change in x
We can find it numerically
I will draw it graphically quickly
What is the change in y?
The change in y is about how much
The shift in y values ​​from this point to that point?
How much is the change in y values?
Y moves from here, y falls on -6 and moves all
Distance up to positive 6
What is this distance?
The end point will be the y value
Will be a 6-point starting value of y
- 6 or 6 + 6, equal to 12
You can count them
It says 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9
10, 11, 12
When the y value changes by 12, we have to change the value of x
By - what is the change in x /
Same change in y?
Well, we move from x = -1 to
x = 3
is not it? X moves from -1 to 3
We put the end point, ie 3, - the starting point
Ie -1, and equal to 4
If the change in y / change in x equals 12/4 or if
We wanted to write it in the simplest form
It will be 3
Now this explanation is that for every 1 we move
On - let us consider it, let me write in this way
Change in y / change in x = - can say
It's 3 or say 3/1
What shows us that for every 1 we move in
Direction x positive, we will move up by 3 because
Positive 3 towards y
You can see it
When we move 1 by x, we move up y by 3
If you move 2 by x, it will
We move on y by 6
6/2 = 3
This 3 shows us how fast we move up when the value of x increases
Let's do the same thing for the second line on this graphic representation
Graph b
same idea
I will use the points given to us
But in fact you can use any points on this line
To see, we have one point here, namely
Point 0.1
We have 0,1
Then the starting point - we can call this the end point -
The starting point here, we can consider
x = -6 and y = -2
The same idea
What is the change in y that gives a change in x?
Let's find the change in x first. What is the
Change in x?
In this case, what is the change in x? Ie delta x
We can calculate it
It's 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
It will be 6
But if you do not have a graph until you count it, you can
Take the location of the end x, it's 0, and
It is removed from the beginning of x
0 - 6
When the change in x = - the result is 6 -
What is the change in y?
Remember, we take this as an end point
This is the starting point
If we take 0 - 6
Then on y, ask 1 - -2
How much product 1 - -2?
It is equivalent to 1 + 2
It is equal to 3
If it is 3/6 1/2
Note that when we move towards x by 6, we will move
Towards y by positive 3
If the change in y is 3 when the change in x is 6
Now, one of the things that bother many people is
How do I know the order - How do I know I am putting 0
First and 6 Second and then 1 First
Then II
The answer is you can put any order you like
As long as you keep them straight
You can also put the change in y
/ Change in x
We can say, it's worth -2-1
If we use this coordinate first. 2
For y divided by -6-0
Note that this negative image of it
This negative image of it
But since we have a negative divided by a negative, it will
We delete them
Thus the result is -3 / -6
Negative is deleted
The result is 1/2
The important thing is if you use this y coordinate
First, you'll have to use
X This is first
If you use this y coordinate, as we have here, if
You must use this x coordinate
First, as I did here
Just make sure that the change in x and
Change in y - using the same
Cut the end and the beginning
So I explain this, this explains it to all
6. We move it to x
If we move on x by -6, we can go back
We will move on y by 3
This explains the same thing
The mile of this line is 1/2
Which shows that for every 2 we move on x, we will move up to y by 1
Or if we return 2 by x, we will go down on y by 1
This is illustrated by Mile 1/2
Note, the line that tilts 1/2, will be less than one step from
The line is tilted 3
Let us solve more of these issues
Let's move to the line c
I will use pink color
Suppose the starting point - I chose it in a way
random
Well, I use these points drawn here
The starting point on the coordinates 1.6 and
The end point is 5, -6
The inclination would be - let me write this - the inclination
Equals the change in the x-zero, the change in y
I will not forget that
Change in y / change in x
It is sometimes said to be height / dimension
The dimension is the amount of movement on the horizontal direction
The rise is the amount of movement on the vertical direction
Then you can say that the change in y is a y endpoint
- starting point y
This is the end point y
This is the starting point y / x endpoint
End point x
If this bothers you, all I say is, it is
Equals the end point y, ie 6 -
Starting point y, ie 6, / x end point
Ie 5, - starting point x, ie -1
This equals -6-6 = -12
= 6
Ie = 12/6
This is equivalent to -2
Note that we have a negative tendency here
The reason is that each time we increase the value of x by 1, we will go down
Towards y
This line of inclination is descending
Moves from top left to bottom right
The higher x, y will be
That's why we got negative inclination
This line must have a positive inclination
Let's check it out
I will use the same points
Used here
If this line d
Tilt = Height / Dimension
How much height do we move from these points to those?
lets see
We can use this method
We rise - I can promise
We rise 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
We rise by 6
How much is our height?
We will move - use a different color
We will move 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
We move by 6
If the tilt is 6/6, ie 1
What shows us that for every 1 we move towards x
- 1 in x - we will move by positive 1
Towards y
For each x, if we move to -2 towards x
We will move to -2 towards y
Whatever we do in x, we will do the same thing in
y in this inclination
Note that this is very easy
If we want to do mathematically, we can
To find this coordinate
This can be seen as the starting site
The starting location is -2, -4
The end location is 4.2
4.2
If inclination, change in y / change in x
I'll take this point 2 - -4 / 4 -
2 - -4 = 6
Remember that it is this distance
Then 4 - -2, also 6
It is this distance
We get the inclination 1
Let's solve one another
Or let's solve a bunch of examples
It's fun
Let us solve the line e
Change in y / change in x
If the change in y, when we move from this point to this
Point - I will count
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8
It's 8
Or you can follow the y coordinate which is 2 -
-6, and will give you the distance which is 8
What is the change in y?
Well, the value of y here is - ah, what is the change in x?
The value of x here is 4
The x value does not change
If it is 8/0
Well, do not know
8/0 undefined number
In this case the tilt is not defined
When we have a vertical line, we say
The inclination is undefined
Because we divide by 0
But this shows that we are dealing with
Vertical line
Let's solve another question
It seems to be a matter of direct inclination
Here
We have that point, which is
3.1
If this line f
Our point is 3.1
Then here we have a point -6, -2
The inclination will be the change in y
I'll take this as an end point, so you can go on
Different directions
If the change in y - now we will move to
Down in this direction
It's -2-1
It is the distance
-2 - 1 = -3
Notice that we moved down by 3
Then what would be the change in x?
Well, we'll go back just as much
What is that amount?
Well, it would be -6, those are
Endpoint, -3
It gives us that distance, I-9
For each 9 we go back, we will go down by 3
If we return 9, we will go down by 3
It is the same if we advance by 9
We will rise by 3
All are equal
As we see, these are deleted and we get the inclination of 1/3
Positive 1/3
Milan line is up
Each time we move by 3, we will rise by 1
Anyway, I wish it was a good review of the mile